نعم نعم جمال كنت اشير الى ذلك ان في في
عنتاب وايضا في خط الزلزال اضافه الى
مناطق في شمال سوريا بعض مراسلين هنا
بالتواصل قالوا انهم شعروا بهذه الهزه وان
كانت على مقياس سته فاصله ولكنها كما اشرت
جمال كفيله
بانهيار المباني التي تصدعت بشكل كبير في
هذه المحافظات العشره التي اصابها الزلزال
في الاسبوعين الماضيين هناك هناك ابنيه
كانت الهائله للسقوط وكانت السلطات تحذر
المواطنين من العوده اليها او المحاوله
لاستخراج
ما بقي من متاعهم او اؤكد مره اخرى اننا
من مكاننا هنا في مدينه انطاكيا سمعنا
اصواتا لانهيار بعض المباني كان هناك ايضا
اصوات لبعض الانفجارات هناك ربما هذا عائد
لخطوط الغاز لا نشاهد حرائق على الاقل حتى
الان في هذا الجو الذي عمه كما فيكم
الكاميرا عما هو الظلام هنا هناك حاله من
الاستنفار ما تشاهدونه من عربات هذه عربات
منها تابع لقوات الجيش ومنها تابع لقوات
لافراد الصوار الكوارث في مدينه في مدينه
انطاكيا عاصمه
الكهرباء على مد البصر جمال مقطوعه في
المنطقه علما انها استردت منذ اليوم
الثالث او الرابع لحدوث هذا الزلزال حاله
من الاستنفار حاله من الهلع مره اخرى سكان
الخيام في هذه الارض المنبسطه كلهم خرجوا
من خيامهم عاشوا واستذكروا لحظات الهلع
الكل الان بدا يتحدث يسال عن اقاربه ان
كانوا بخير وكما تشاهد هناك ايضا بعض من
فرق
هذه وحدات للتدخل الصحي السريع هنا في
تركيا هناك وحدات ايضا باتجاه المدينه هذا
هذا الاتجاه ياخذ الى وسط المدينه انطاكيا
كما قلت كما تزال بعض الفرق تعمل على
استخراج بعض الناجين المحتمنين في مدينه
انطاكيا الحديث عن مجموع النقاط التي
ماتزال تعمل فيها
وحدات من
الحماء وحدات من فرق الطوارئ التركيه نحو
من الاربعين النقطه 19 منها في ولايه
مرعش والاخرى هنا الباقي 29 نقطه هنا داخل
مدينه هاتاي ولكن خلال جوانا في المدينه
نستطيع ان نؤكد ان الكثير من الابنيه اما
مائله او عائله للسقوط هذه الهزه الكبيره
التي وقعت قبل اقل من عشر دقائق من الان
كفيله بلا شك بحدهم الكثير من هذه المباني
واتركك اترككم الان مع هذه الصور هناك
وحدات من كما ذكرت الجيش وايضا من الطوارئ
تتوج تستعد هنا للتوجه الى داخل المدينه
ربما لتفقد فرق الطوارئ التي كما اشرت
تعمل منذ ايام في مواقع يعتقد ان هناك بعض
اللاجئين ما يزاهه بعض
محاوله لايجاد ناجين محتملين داخل المدينه
جمال